foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday January 20th I'm Zoe Thomas
for the Wall Street Journal
one of the biggest leaps in lightning
protection technology since Ben Franklin
came up with the lightning rod was
announced this week for the first time
an international group of researchers
demonstrated that it was possible to use
lasers to guide the path of lightning
these findings could help open new ways
for protecting people landscapes and
businesses from lightning damage and
destruction joining us to discuss this
experiment is our science reporter
Island Woodward hi Island thanks for
joining us thanks so much for having me
so just before we get into how this
technology Works can you give us a sense
of just how damaging lightning strikes
can be
absolutely so while the statistics vary
somewhat lightning can cause thousands
of casualties per year and it also can
be damaging to buildings and
infrastructure
airports and it can also actually delay
rocket launches places like NASA have
very strict launch weather criteria in
place where if a strike happens within a
certain amount of time and a certain
amount of distance of a rocket launch it
can delay that launch okay so let's talk
a bit about this experiment lasers were
used to guide the pathway of lightning
can you talk to us a little bit about
how that worked I mean I assume these
weren't just like regular laser pointers
so the laser that was used in this
particular study was built specifically
for this experimental campaign it's a
prototype laser about the size of a car
and it's a very high powered
laser that's capable of sending out
these short intense
pulses along a laser beam and they
assembled this laser at the top of a
Swiss Peak next to an existing
telecommunications tower that was
about 124 meters tall and at the top of
that telecommunications Tower there was
already a lightning rod existing and the
concept behind sort of laser-guided
lightning as it were is that this
high-powered laser and the short intense
pulses that come out of it they're
capable of heating the air
and ionizing the air the reason for this
is that lightning is actually fairly
arbitrary process it's the result of
opposing electrical charges and clouds
in the ground and everything in between
and the connection of those two is what
creates a lightning strike but the way
this Laser Technology works is that
we're artificially creating sort of
these preferred Pathways that lightning
will take instead that we can then guide
to where we want which in this case
happen to be a lightning rod are there
other Technologies in use at the moment
that can guide where Lightning goes
sure so the most common lightning
protection device is actually the same
one that's been around for almost 300
years it was devised by Benjamin
Franklin
and it's called a Franklin Rod
appropriately named and it's an
electrically conductive metallic stick
that's on the tops of buildings it's
used in like City skylines and things
and what it does is it sort of helps
provide a path for lightning strikes to
safely follow to the ground the problem
with a traditional lightning rod the
researchers explained to me is that they
can only offer limited protection so if
you place a rod that's 10 meters high it
can only protect a radius of 10 meters
and that doesn't really work so well if
you want to predict like a rocket launch
pad or an airport or other sensitive
installations like a power plant
it's great for a house but it's not
great for sort of these sprawling
sensitive installations
so in this particular experiment they
did it in the wild they showed that they
were capable of guiding lightning
previous experiments they were sort of
guiding the electrical equivalent of
lightning but it wasn't lightning it was
in a lab and it was only over distances
of like two meters for instance here
they did it with real lightning for a
distance of up to 60 meters
nearly 200 feet and so the next step now
is to make that 200 foot distance even
longer so to be able to guide lightning
for hundreds of meters if not kilometers
one of the researchers would really like
to take this laser and bring it down to
sort of sea level so off the mountain
top and test it near an airport sort of
in a situation in which they hope that
it'll one day be applicable for and in
order to really achieve these Next Step
results they think they need a higher
energy laser which might necessitate a
bigger laser
but either way they mentioned that you
know the commercial applications for
this is at least a decade out if not
more so then how
simple uses are at least 10 years away
the way both the study authors and other
physicists who were not involved in the
research explained it to me is that it's
really a proof of concept one of them
likened it to the recent results out of
a U.S lab regarding nuclear fusion where
they sort of showed that it was possible
to get more energy out than you put into
a nuclear fusion experiment they say
it's the same concept here is that this
was something that they had been
striving to achieve laser-guided
lightning since almost the Inception of
the laser like 50 60 years ago but it
had never really been demonstrated as
possible until now so now that it's been
demonstrated a lot of the thought
process here is that this space will see
a lot more investment there'll be a lot
more research now that they know it can
be done it's just a matter of
tweaking the laser to make longer
distances possible and then working
towards maybe smaller lasers maybe
making it so assembling it isn't quite
so difficult and steps like that all
right that was our science reporter
Island Woodward Island thanks so much
for joining us thanks so much for having
me Zoe
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories check out
our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]
thank you